حل الليل في خاركيف وعمال الانقاذ مستمرون
في عمليات البحث عن ناجين تحت
الانقاض مبنى الاكاديميه القانونيه دمر
بفعل صواريخ الروسيه عشرات المباني الاخرى
تضررت والعديد من الاشخاص سقطوا بين قتيل
وجريح رجال الانقاظ يعملون لاخراج الناس
من تحت الانقاظ هناك الكثير من
الاضرار نظام الدفاع الجوي الاوكراني لم
ينجح في صد كل الصواريخ
الروسيه
اطلق نحو 40 صاروخا من انواع مختلفه في
ضربه مركبه لتخطي نظام دفاعنا الجوي اسقط
الكثير من هذه الصواريخ لكن للاسف لم تمنع
كل
الضربات تنفذ القوات الروسيه ضربات مركبه
تطلق صواريخ من الجو والبر وهو ما يصعب
التصدي لها لذلك تكرر كيف مطلبها الى
شركائها الغربيين لمدها بانظمه دفاع جوي
متقدمه العاصمه كيف لم تسلم من الصواريخ
التي اصابت مركزها وطالت مبان قريبه من
مكتب الامم
المتحده كنا خارجين من المنزل عندما سقط
الصاروخ واحدث انفجارا حطم النوافذ الجيش
الروسي لا يستهدف المدنيين الاوكرانيين
يقول المتحدث باسم الرئيس الروسي لا يضرب
جيشنا المرافق الاجتماعيه والمناطق
السكنيه لا يضرب المدنيين على العكس من
نظام كيف قواتنا مختلفه تماما عن قوات
نظام كيف ونفى الكريملين تماما ان يكون
الهجوم على كيف وخاركوف رد من موسكو على
الهجوم القاتل الذي طال مدينه دونيتسك
التي تحتلها روسيا في شرق اوكرانيا